voilà ville où tout cela hier
[Musique]
ça promet
un centre de planification familiale est
un service du département
il y a dix centres de planification
family d'éducation familiale sur l'île
de la réunion
répartie sur toute l'île avec des
équipes pluridisciplinaires des médecins
des sages-femmes des agents de
planification des conseillères
conjugales pour tout les gens qui
souhaitent accompagner dans leur dans
leur vie affective à leur vie sexuelle
dans leur vie familiale
alors jeanne bonjour moi je perds mais
je te tutoie
oui on le vit à écoute tu viens
aujourd'hui explique moi pourquoi
qu'est ce qui était arrivé binger
incombait rapport sexuel liège et je me
suis papou tg d'accord
du coup je voulais savoir les solutions
possibles tu peux me dire quand c'était
des dernières règles principalement va
recevoir des jeunes inférieur à 25 ans
mais surtout des jeunes mineurs pourquoi
parce que c'est ici un lieu de
confidentialité d'anonymat et c'est
surtout un lieu de gratuité pour les
jeunes mineurs donc on va leur proposer
une contraception très souvent elles
viennent pour leur première
contraception
on va pouvoir enlever notre masque
puisqu'on est à distance toutes les deux
et on va pouvoir mieux parler voilà tu
veux pas en parler à tes parents
c'est difficile wei ses tableaux
d'accords conclus par rapport à ce
rapport sexuel oui je vais te donner une
contraception d'urgence qu'on peut
appeler aussi contraception du lendemain
ces patates tu es venu très tôt c'est
bien et donc je vais te donner ça
aujourd'hui puis ensuite on va discuter
si tu voulais une première contraception
oui tu voudrais prendre ta contraception
bien pour la descente je veux pas en
parler d'un moment ça va être difficile
d'accord
[Musique]
quand elles vont venir ici elles vont
pouvoir parler en toute confidentialité
savoir que ces anonymes et elles vont
repartir avec leur pilule on va leur
expliquer les différentes contraception
qui existe celle qui est plus adapté
pour à elles vont ensuite pouvoir
repartir avec leur pilule et revenir
ensuite ça doit être des questions elles
seront toujours quelqu'un qui prend les
renseignez vous donc à la pilule déjà
qui se peut se prendre tous les jours ou
qui peut s'arrêter une semaine au bout
de trois semaines
il faut que ce soit quand même du
quotidien et bien quand même régulier
ensuite tu 1
le patch c'est une pilule donc tu va
coller le patch tu vois hélas et tu en
mets par semaine donc là on n'ait pu
tous les jours on est par semaine donc
tu vas mettre 3 patch danton mois et une
semaine et tu vas pas mettre le patch ou
tu vas avoir tiré et puis après tu as la
nos qui pareille dans l'anneau contient
la pilule tu vois il n'y a pas ça
évidemment là que l'agneau et ça ça se
met à l'intérieur de ton vagin
il faut que tu sois assez à l'aise avec
mon corps prom et sarah et ça ça se met
au fond de ton vagin et ça c'est bien ce
que ça se garde trois semaines le petit
inconvénient de ces deux contraceptifs
que je viens de te parler c'est qu'ils
sont pas remboursés ensuite tu as
l'implant voici un petit bout de
plastique un petit peu damas tient un
petit scooby doo tu vois qui est très
court et qui se met dans le bras et
qu'il a va être posée pour trois ans il
ya des petits effets secondaires tu peux
avoir des saignements un peu tous les
jours donc là c'est vraiment un effet
secondaire qui est pas forcément très
bien toléré
et puis après on en vient aux
dispositifs intra-utérins qui en cuivre
tu vois qui va ne pas apporter
d'hormones et qui va te protéger très
très bien qui va on peut mettre un
stérilet un dispositif intra utérin
aujourd'hui même qu'on n'en a pas eu
d'enfants est ce assez pour cinq ans et
puis tu as les dispositifs intra-utérins
hormonaux août est un tout petit peu
d'hormones qui sont dans le dispositif
et qui vont quotidiennement à
l'intérieur de ton utérus et pas
diffusés dans tout ton corps d'être un
petit peu d'ordre et qui vont
généralement tu auras moins de règles
avec ce genre de dispositif un
traducteur et puis de talent et
préservatifs féminins d'accord que si
ton partenaire pas mettre bien sache que
toi tu peux mettre un préservatif est
sage comme je le disais dès le départ
c'est pour te protéger dans un premier
temps des infections sexuellement
transmissibles
[Musique]
tu as compris tu as vu un petit peu ce
qui s'offre à toi tu sais que la
compresse la contraception ça doit être
toi qui dois l'a choisie par rapport à
ton ta discrétion avec tes parents par
rapport à tes habitudes
donc on propose tout en fonction du
choix de la patiente
ça va de la pile du dispositif intra
utérin de l'implant on pousse beaucoup
d'aplomb retire beaucoup d'un plan on va
aussi proposer à nos le patch et on va
pouvoir fournir à ces jeunes
cette contraception qu'elles vont venir
en toute confidentialité ses amis c'est
gratuit c'est confidentiel
[Musique]